MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
everybody to another--
this is not authors at Google.
This is astronauts
at the Google Talk.
Today we have
Commander Reid Wiseman,
was a flight engineer
on Expedition 41,
which launched from
Kazakhstan on May 28, 2014
on board a Soyuz 39,
and he spent-- what?
Five months on
the space station?
REID WISEMAN: Five
and a half months.
MALE SPEAKER: Five
So when he was aboard
the space station
you can imagine he did a
lot of interesting things,
like repairing things,
surviving in space,
which is-- like you're away
from friends and family.
You have strange
friends, probably,
up there that you're
not picking yourself.
Let's see.
So they replaced a
failed power regulator,
and prepped the station
for a reconfiguration that
will allow the
station to accommodate
future commercial crew vehicles
inside the space station.
Is that the code
name for SpaceX?
We'll hear about that.
Anyway, so Reid was born
in Baltimore, Maryland.
Married to the former Carroll
Taylor of Virginia Beach,
Virginia.
They have two daughters,
and Wiseman's parents,
Bill and July Wiseman, reside
in Hunt Valley, Maryland.
He graduated from Dulaney
High School in Maryland.
Bachelor of Science
degree in computer
and systems engineering.
Recruiters?
Are there any recruiters here?
From the Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute in New York.
Master's of Science
degree in systems
engineering at John Hopkins
University Baltimore, Maryland.
Please join me in welcoming
Reid Wiseman to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
REID WISEMAN: But
just real quick.
This is my second
trip to Google.
There was a former
astronaut, Ed Lu,
who worked here
for a little while,
and he took me on a
tour a couple years ago.
And, wow, this place
is so much bigger now.
I mean, it's amazing.
And so I was reflecting just
while we were sitting there
waiting lunch at the
great cafe, I just
started to step back for a
second and think about Google
in my own personal
life, and holy smokes.
I mean-- bless you.
When we're on the
space station we're
running Picasa with
all of our photos.
When I'm here, I don't even
think about my search engine.
It's just Google.
That's where all my news comes.
That's where all my internet
information comes from.
When I landed in San
Francisco airport
and I'm driving
down here, that's
where my directions come from.
My dad, he offered
me his GPS when
I was home so I get around
Maryland and I'm like, Dad.
Come on.
I got Google maps here.
I mean, I got the whole
world right in my hand.
So when you take a step
back and realize the work
that everyone here is
doing, and how much you all
are changing the world,
it just blows me away.
And so it's really a great
honor for me to be here.
Google's intertwined
beautifully into my life,
and I personally appreciate all
the work that's going on here.
And I get to see one of
my old friends, which
was totally by surprise,
which was really cool.
Brandon, we used
to work together.
So if you'll humor me
I'll talk for, hopefully,
no more than about 25 minutes.
I just want to run you through
the basis of my mission.
Give you a little feeling
for what it's like in space.
It might be a bit
generic for this crowd,
but then if I can get some
questions from people--
because the way you all
think is just brilliant,
and I really hope I get some
interesting, odd questions
that I can't answer.
And then we'll go to
Google, we'll hit Wikipedia,
and we will find the
solution to these problems.
So just jumping right in.
I did have to show a picture
of me at the dining facility
this afternoon.
I would throw on-- I put on
about 10 pounds in space eating
space today.
I set the record for most
weight gain up there,
and it was all due to
chocolate pudding cake,
and you can see that started
when I was about one year old.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
technically just mass gain?
REID WISEMAN:
That's a good point.
It was just mass gain, but
I'll tell you when I landed,
it was definitely weight gain.
[LAUGHTER]
I had to buy a whole
new set of pants.
We did the introduction, so this
is me and my family growing.
I got an older brother Bill
who's five years older than me,
and he got all the
brains the family,
so he is just a huge thinker,
and I love talking to him.
He's way outside my league.
I went to RPI for
Rensselaer When I was there,
I really loved computers.
I loved computer networking.
And I really wanted
to work at Intel,
but there was something just
burning in me that I also
wanted to fly airplanes.
And so, when I left
Rensselaer I joined the Navy,
and I got super lucky to
fly F-14s and F-18s off
of aircraft carriers.
I spent about two a
half years of my life
at sea over this 12
year career in the Navy,
and then I got to
go to Patuxent River
and do a lot of test pilot work
on some really new systems.
I wasn't doing too much on new
airplanes but on new systems,
and so when I look
at the way you all
invent, test, integrate,
reredesign-- to me
that's the best.
That's the best.
When you take hardware,
look at how it works, tweak
the software, and then re-go.
It's just awesome.
So that was my
life for 12 years.
And then in 2009, about 5,000
people wanted to come to NASA,
and for some reason they
selected this group,
and I was lucky enough to be one
of the nine Americans selected
in '09.
It's just a whole lot of luck.
I had a nice background
with the military test
pilot and a couple degrees.
But the reason I want to
show you all this picture
is, this is the first time in
our lives that we had floated.
It was in the back of a C-9.
If any of you have ever done a
zero-G flight-- if you haven't
and you have a little spare
money, which maybe some of you
do, I recommend it.
It's a total-- you can see from
our faces it's no fun at all,
but it's great.
And the reason I want
to show this is this
was the 2009 class,
and I think it looks
a lot like the Google campus.
There's a lot of folks
from different countries,
a lot of different
languages being spoke,
we have Serena Aunon--
she's a medical doctor.
Mike Hopkins here is an
Air Force test engineer--
I know one of those
in the front--
and then we have a few
other medical doctors.
Kate Rubens, she's just barely
peaking her blonde head out
in the back, and she
is like a bio genius.
And she was studying
Ebola in the Congo
when she was selected
to NASA, and so they
had to fly her out of there.
Super smart.
So anyway, NASA's
just a great-- just
like you guys-- a great,
diverse collection of folks
that all come together and
try to do really fun things.
In 2011, I was lucky enough
to be assigned to a mission,
and this is my primary
crew that I flew with.
Obviously I'm on
the right there.
In the center is a great, great
crazy character, Max Surayev.
He's a Russian.
He was a Russian
Air Force pilot,
so for my first five years
in the Navy he was the enemy,
and then in the end he's
just my best friend.
And he's got two daughters.
I have two daughters.
They all know each
other really well.
We teach them English.
They teach us Russian.
And once you get below
the political tensions
of the US-Russia relationship,
when you get down to the people
and you work together
with these people,
you realize they're
just great folks.
And everybody's there for the
common goal, and I love that.
Over here on the
left is Alex Gerst.
He was our resident
smart guy in our crew.
He is a geophysicist, a
volcanologist by trade.
Grew up in Germany,
and he flew with us
with the European Space Agency.
And he was like our
encyclopedia of knowledge,
and you cannot get
anything past him.
If you're off by even
1,000th, he will correct you
on everything, and so it's
really fun to play with him
because he kept us
sharp the whole time.
Now I'll just jump into
a series of about two
and a half to three
minute video clips.
I was part of the 40th
and 41st expedition
to the International
Space Station.
We've flying to this thing since
about 2000, which was amazing.
And for me, I'd always dreamed
of leaving in our planet,
and this is the day.
There's me saying
goodbye to my two
daughters, which was the hardest
part, by far, of the mission.
And I was on the bus heading
out to the launch pad there.
We get in our suits,
and we walk out.
And this guy hugging us is
the head of the Russian Space
Agency, and I loved
what he said to me.
He just said, hey,
everything's gonna be fine.
We built a great rocket for you.
It's going to work.
It was exactly what I
needed to hear before I
jumped on a bunch of fuel.
And this is us
climbing up the ladder,
and you see behind us just the
steam coming off of this thing.
It was alive sitting in there.
Once they light the engines
it's about three hours
we've already been sitting in
there, but it's super calm.
We were so calm.
You'll see when we switch
to the inside view.
It's just a really
gentle liftoff.
You don't even realize
you're in space.
You can see us shake
a little bit there,
and then we're on our way.
It was about 2:00
AM when we launched.
This is a picture of
my family watching,
so the only thing
lighting them up right
now is our plume from
our rocket, which
was making my mom
very nervous, but I
think it's a cool picture.
And then off we go.
We go about 17,000 miles
an hour in the end,
and it's only a nine minute
ride--a little over nine
minutes.
So the force of
acceleration the whole time
is pretty impressive.
You see that's us inside
and we're riding into space,
and it just looks
calm as can be.
Mainly because we
don't have that view,
and we don't know the
gravity of the situation,
no pun unintended.
And so it's the Soyuz
Russian-built rocket.
I launched out of Kazakhstan.
It's a three stage rocket.
The first stage
has five engines,
so it's a pretty powerful
kick towards the end.
About four and a half
times the force of gravity.
And this is us, actually,
at engine cut off,
so now we're in space
floating, and you
can see it's pretty dynamic.
But then the best
part hits you when
you realize that you just
went through this crazy thing
and you're alive.
And the raw emotion here, I
think, is pretty much perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
And then, of course,
the next thing
is-- that's a toy from my
daughter floating around there
that we had tied to the hatch.
And then, we had a
couple GoPros with us,
and I grabbed it off the
wall, and I decided--
the view outside, of course,
is what it's all about,
and that was just amazing.
And so, that's
not a NASA Studio.
That's reality.
[LAUGHTER]
I was there.
And this is us getting ready
to dock to the space station.
It's about a six
hour ride as we're
phasing with the space
station-- catching up--
which is extremely quick.
It used to take us
two days, but now they
just do a really accurate
insertion on ascent,
and they throw us right
at the space station.
Cool thing for the
aero folks here.
Totally automated.
The entire ride
uphill is automated.
We have no controls whatsoever.
If anything went
wrong it was based
on the rocket deciding for
itself that something was wrong
and basically ejecting
us off the top of it.
The entire rendezvous sequence
here I didn't touch anything.
All I was doing was keeping
us alive with our life support
systems, and the
rocket did everything.
And the right side there is up
docking in the space station,
and the left side is our
little tiny launch vehicle.
Now, the first time
you get to float I
thought it'd be this
magical, crazy experience,
but in reality it's
very uncomfortable.
Nothing feels right.
You don't know how to do it.
Everything is
awkward and clumsy.
All your food is up at
the top of your throat,
and you're trying
to swallow it down.
At this point we hadn't gone to
the bathroom in about 10 hours,
so the first words we uttered
as we came through the hatch
was, where's the bathroom?
He have got to go.
Alex was the first through
the hatch for our crew,
and then I came through third.
And you can see, just the look
on my face-- I mean, I'm lost.
I've trained for five years,
basically, for this moment
and I'm completely lost
because when you just take away
gravity from the situation, it
does crazy things to your mind.
There were already three
astronauts up there-- one
American and two
Russians-- when we got up.
And they had been up
for about two months,
and then we joined them,
and we became a crew of six.
Little time lapse of
the view, and then-- we
didn't get to shoot
this video, but it's
a neat view of the space
station from outside.
Let me see if this
laser pointer works.
So when you look--
we're in San Francisco.
We're the ultimate
green machine,
so all our power comes from
those eight solar arrays.
Of course, I think it's like
a million pounds in orbit,
so we kind of crushed some
of the environment getting it
all up there.
But once it's up there it's
totally self supportive.
We live in the
center stack here.
I'm sorry to use
the mouse pointer,
but this is kind of our
habitable area right there.
This back half is the Russian
segment, and we go down there
and do some work
from time to time.
And then this forward half
is all the Russian, Japanese,
and European segments, and it's
just bustling with activity.
This cross structure that
runs left to right here, all
that does is just holds up
our solar arrays, and then
our thermal panels,
which you see out here.
And really the whole goal
of this entire operation
is first, to do general
research and see
what happens to things
when you remove gravity
from the situation.
But in reality,
this is the platform
that we will do the most
learning to go deeper
into space, and I'll
kind of touch on that
here in a couple of minutes.
But first-- ah, it's going
to play automatically.
I wanted to give you
guys this feeling of what
it's like when you just
take gravity away because it
captured my imagination.
And I never was an operational
engineer or scientist,
but when I got into
space, really what you are
is just a kid.
Your inquisitive,
and it's just crazy.
Some of you may have seen this.
We decided to build
a water bubble
and stick a GoPro
inside of it, just
to see what it would
look like from the video.
And so all these little
spheres are little air pockets
inside this larger
bubble that we had built.
And watching something-- you
can see there's Steve Swanson.
He's a PhD in computer
science, and just watching
him behave like a little
child, and just giggling
over this water bottle.
I just-- I loved it.
I loved every minute of that.
And it was great.
That's Oleg Artemiev, a Russian.
Then I thought, what is the
surface tension of water?
Will these two
bubbles bounce off,
or will they stick together?
And so in this case
they stuck together,
but they had some pretty
good mass to them.
So then I got out a syringe
with a Teflon catheter
and I started making these
little water bubbles.
And this pretty much ended
an entire Saturday afternoon
for me.
I couldn't stop playing with
this stuff, and you'll see why.
If you have enough force to
break the service tension
you add to your bubble.
If you don't, you just
bounce little bubbles off
of this bigger water bubble.
And then, the water
bubble's a lens.
You can see my head in the
water bubble upside down there.
And the closest thing that
I came to a shower in space
were these little bubbles
bouncing off there.
So then I'll add some water
here, and then halfway
through I'm just adding a little
bit of water and I thought, oh,
would happen if I added air?
Would it pop the bubble?
Would I build air inside?
So that an air bubble now
being added to a water bubble,
and it just bounces around the
inside of the water bubble.
It was amazing to me.
You'll see I hit
it from the side
and I actually bounce the
air bubble off the other side
of the bubble, and
then the air bubble
is its own little
lens inside there.
You can see my face
in the air bubble.
But then we decided we got to
put a human inside the water
bubble, and so we built
one more water bubble.
And since Alex Gerst
didn't have hair,
he was the one that was
going in the water bubble.
And so you'll see here
we did it with him.
It's amazing.
The scariest thing is
afterwards he was like, wow,
I could have drowned
in that water bubble
without any problem.
[LAUGHTER]
At Google you guys have
amazing imaginations,
and that should kind of set it.
So the real reason that we're
up there is the science,
and to me the science
is three phases.
There is the core science--
this is my first week up there.
I'm going to whack my head
on the floor here, I think.
I knew it was coming.
But we kind of got this
three phase science.
We're doing physical science
about a third of our day.
We're doing maintenance
about a third of our day,
but living on an
orbiting outpost,
I think that
maintenance is probably
some of the best
science we do up there.
Learning how to
fix our own machine
and keep this thing going
without too much ground
support.
And then the third phase is just
keeping our body in good shape,
and we were all lab
experiments up there.
And so more blood has
been taken from me
than I ever thought possible.
Some of this is-- we have these
autonomous satellites here.
They could either
work off of CO2,
or here we have these
electromagnetic rings
around them, and we were
trying to do different orbiting
station keeping
experiments with just
using electromagnetic forces.
And it worked OK.
It was pretty good.
A lot of this is MIT based
research, and some of it's
going on over at AEMS.
We also strapped a cell
phone onto these satellites
and used the cellphone to
map inside of the station.
And the satellites
knew where they are,
and they could fly
all over the place.
But the most fun science
that I got to be a part of
was towards the end of my
mission, we flew up 20 mice,
and that was another NASA
AEMS based research thing.
And just watching these mice
go from scared little animals
on day one, two, and
three on space station
to the end when I saw
them around day 40,
and these guys were completely
adapted to floating.
They would float from their
cheese over to their water,
and they'd even learn how
to run around the cage
to build themselves a little
exercise machine up there,
and you would watch them.
They were all female.
One little girl would run
around, then she would jump off
and another one would
come and run around.
And it was really cool to watch.
From my perspective, it was
neat to watch them adapt.
And then from the
science perspective,
they're little organisms
are going so fast,
it's like watching
a human, almost,
over their entire
lifetime in space,
and see how their bone
density is changing,
their muscles are wasting.
And I think down the road
the research that we can
get from that will be awesome.
We also did a lot of work
with protein crystal growth.
A lot of colloidal research to
see how things settle or don't
settle without gravity.
That's me mixing up some
stuff for Procter & Gamble.
In any given day we were
running-- each one of us
was around about five
hours of physical science.
And the best part, I
guess, overall, we're
tied directly in with the
investigators on the ground.
Talking to them on a radio.
They've got a camera
over our shoulder.
And we've flown in
space since the 1960s,
but every time I did an
experiment the PI on the ground
would go, whoa, do that again.
I totally didn't expect that.
And it's just pulling away
gravity and then running these
experiments, I would've thought
we had researched the life out
of low Earth orbit,
but we hadn't.
I mean, everything
we were doing was
kind of surprising
to these researchers,
and that made it fun.
Here's about two months in, and
I'm not going to hit my head
but I missed the grab up there.
[LAUGHTER]
But getting better.
Less injuries.
And this kind of going
into maintenance.
This is our water regen system.
So it takes all of our urine,
if processes it through here,
and turns it back
into drinking water.
It takes the sweat, it takes
any condensation out of the air,
so we run pretty low humidity.
It takes about three days
to cycle through that thing,
so urine three days later
becomes your drinking water.
Urine and sweat,
and it was great.
I mean, we were reclaiming
like 95% of all of our water
up there.
And it's to the point
where they're even
stripping the hydrogen
off the water molecules
to make oxygen to put
it into the cabin,
so it turns into our
breathing air as well.
So that's the 5%
that we're losing.
This is us tearing
apart a space suit
that I'm going to do a space
walk in about a month later.
And so the
maintenance that we're
doing, knowing that I'm
working on my space suit
that I'm about to
do a space walk in,
was absolutely terrifying.
There was no way
that I should be
pulling pumps out of this
thing and changing them.
And this is Swanee working
on the toilet, which
is absolutely critical gear,
and when that thing broke it
basically-- everything
stopped on station,
and we would work to fix it.
So you're handyman to
the highest degree,
and working on this complicated
stuff with the ground teams
was really awesome.
And then, kind of
the third major part
was looking at my body, and I
became a fantastic ultrasound
tech looking at my calf
muscles, my thigh muscle,
seeing how they're changing.
My calves changed so
much it was unbelievable.
They all went from the back of
my calf around to the front,
around my shin area, because
you're just not walking.
And you're using
the top of your feet
to lock under
handrails so you can
keep yourself stationary because
Newton wins every argument up
there.
So it's a different way to work.
And then our eyes, because
your blood kind of pools
all throughout your body
and not down at your legs,
and puts a lot of pressure
on the back of your eyes,
so we did lots of research
on the blood vessels,
and what's going on
with the pressure.
Some astronauts experience
total sight change
and they have to wear
reading glasses by the end.
I was young enough that it
didn't affect me too much,
but ultrasounding my own eye.
All my heart valves
ultrasounded overtime.
Carotid artery, brachial
artery, and this
is how we keep
ourselves in shape.
We actually have a
weight machine up there.
We can do squats
up to 600 pounds.
I'm not anywhere near capable
of that, so was doing squats
up to about 300 pounds.
Which, if you think about it,
since I didn't weigh anything,
is really not impressive at all.
And then we have a
treadmill which I love.
And our treadmill is
actually mounted on the wall,
so this is an Earth based view.
So you're running straight
down at the Earth when you're
running on the treadmill.
And the treadmill is crazy.
The first time I got on
that, just feeling my insides
bouncing up and
down, my food-- you
can feel food bouncing off
the top of your stomach.
It's really interesting.
And your legs would tingle.
And then, who was
talking-- somebody
was talking about some really
cold stuff when I walked in.
Was it you guys?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
It was us.
REID WISEMAN: Yeah, so
our freezers up there
are running anywhere between
minus 90 C and minus 160
C, and all of our
samples that we
want to get ground
analysis we put
in those freezers, slow
everything way down,
and then we send them home
on a Dragon spaceship.
I never liked working
in those freezers.
They were so unbelievably cold.
And why I'm doing
it in short sleeves?
After this I started wearing
long sleeves and long pants.
And so how do we keep
this thing running?
This is a launch of a Orbital.
This is Orbital 2.
If any of you guys
follow space big time,
this is the one
that made it to us,
not the one that
didn't make it to us.
And so what we do is we have
these two companies, Orbital
and SpaceX, and they are
just totally building
their own rockets.
And then we are buying
that service from them,
and launching them up
to the space station,
and it's really, really neat.
I mean, just watching
these two companies work.
They've come to
totally different ways
of doing business, but they've
both been very successful.
And the way we
grab these things,
they don't actually dock.
They just float up next
to us in low Earth orbit.
We take the robotic arm out and
just grab them out of space,
pull them over, and then plug
them into the space station.
That's a view of the Orbital
coming up and getting
plugged in.
Orbital is like a
great pickup truck.
This thing came just loaded
with food and science
for us-- really awesome--
but it can't survive reentry,
so when we get all the
supplies out of it,
now that's where all our trash
goes from the space station.
And let me tell you, if we
ever go somewhere really
far like Mars we got to
take care of our trash
because we filled this
thing completely up.
And you'll see when it reenters
Earth's atmosphere here
in a minute, it's fun to
watch all your trash burn up.
So we release this one, and
I just hit one little button.
That's the go home button.
Obviously, this is a time lapse.
It didn't happen
this fast, but I
love this as like a Jetsons
moment watch the thing.
And it'll go out--
it'll actually
accelerate, go up
over the top of us,
and then it's coming down.
And this was some
research we were doing,
but it kind of almost
captures Orbital reentry
through the atmosphere.
You see the big
tail building there?
And then just as it goes off you
can see some flashes of light,
and then all the
particles of trash
just kind of float
down behind it.
And then the other
main cargo vehicle
that we have is just
right down in Hawthorne,
California where they're
building the SpaceX Dragon,
and this thing is fantastic.
This is like our
science workhorse
because it can survive reentry.
And hopefully in
about three years
we'll be thrown
humans on that thing
and sending them up there.
And this is just a really
fantastic vehicle for us.
So the same thing for Dragon.
It just floats up beside us.
You can see the robotic arm is
ready to go out and grab it,
and we'll go out and
grab it and bring it in.
And I got a good picture of
that thing right over Hawthorne
when I was up there.
It was really nice.
When I look at this,
all I think of is work.
This thing carried so much work.
When we docked SpaceX,
we didn't take a day off
for about 28 days.
I mean, that little tiny capsule
carried that much research
on it.
And it was all fun
stuff, but it was brutal.
We worked almost as hard,
probably as you guys, I guess,
but we were really
cranking through.
So obviously going out
into the vacuum of space,
the only thing that's there to
protect us is the spacesuit.
And this is the one that I've
just replaced the pump on,
so I already was a little
bit nervous about it.
But the thing that I'm
talking about here--
we don't have sound going-- but
I'm pretty afraid of heights.
Like, I couldn't walk up
to the top of a building
and look out over the edge.
It just makes my
stomach go crazy.
And so, I didn't know
when we were starting
these space walks and I had to
be the first one out the hatch,
I know if I could
get out the hatch.
Like can I physically get over
this hurdle of 250 miles up
to get out the hatch?
And so I opened up
the hatch, and all
I looked down on was
the Pacific Ocean.
There was a full moon
beating down on the clouds,
and it was like evil
just inviting me out.
Just come on, Reid.
Come on out.
And I went outside,
and it was awesome.
This is a view from inside
the space station looking up
at the airlock, and this is
me and my German buddy Alex
coming out of the airlock
for the first time
and getting going.
And once you get over the
fact that you're high up,
you just know you let
go and you're just
going to be floating.
We always stay tethered
to the space station.
There's one of the
tethers in my right hand.
It's really just a
phenomenal experience.
The thing that you're
always looking for
is the sound of the fan.
It's kind of blowing air around
the left side of your ear,
and as long as that
fan's going your alive
and you're doing good.
There's a part here where I've
kind of let go and push off,
and it still gives my stomach
like the willies a little bit.
Right there pushing
off, and now I
have no hands on the space
station other than my tether.
We use the big robotic arm.
We actually had Alex Gerst
attached to that thing,
and so he had extended
reach of about 100 feet.
There's him kind of
cruising through outer space
on the end of the
robotic arm, and he's
carrying a gigantic
refrigerator, which
was a pump that had
failed last year,
and we were putting
that thing away.
The view from out
there was amazing.
I got to go all over
the space station.
I went all the way out the
port and starboard side
repairing things.
That's us all messed up
in these bundles of cables
rewiring the robotic arm.
The highest intensity
thing I've ever done,
and the most mentally
and physically grueling.
I came in from that and all
I wanted to do was go to bed.
I was devastated
after both of them.
Just completely worn
out, which is great.
It's a great feeling.
And that's my little body
there working on a pallet.
Attempted a selfie.
And then time to go home.
Home is-- it's a great
feeling to get in that rocket.
I was nervous getting
in, but just like launch,
once you get in you know
it's time to go home.
And it's an extremely
high energy event,
and if something goes wrong,
well, it's just not your day.
So we get in there,
we close a hatch,
we get in these little
space suits that
are going to protect us in case
we have a depressurization,
and then we'll push some
buttons and back away
from the space station.
And we back away, we kind of
go out up over the top again,
and then we'll lighter engines.
Just a little bit
of a deceleration--
about 120 meters per second
deceleration-- and that's
enough just to send us home.
And this is a little
video from inside of us
just a raging fireball
about 3,000 degrees.
And those little
flashes of light
are part of our
blade of heat shield
that are supposed
to be burning off.
But it's crazy
when you're sitting
in there at about
five Gs knowing
it's 3,000 degrees outside and
parts of you are burning up.
It's amazing.
You can see the
window is totally
burned by the end of reentry.
And then after about
five minutes of craziness
the parachute comes out, and
it's just a great 15 minute
ride back down to the earth.
And then you slam home after
six months of weightlessness,
[GROANS] and it's painful.
And we hit down, and
then we tipped over,
and so I wasn't feeling
super well at that point.
And Max, my commander, I
was-- because of the way
we tipped over I was up high,
and then Max and then Alex
was all the way
down on the ground.
And Max says, hey
Reid, how you feeling?
And I said, I think
I'm going to puke, Max.
And Alex is like, no, no,
no because he would have
been right in the line of fire.
So coming home and landing, the
biggest thing that I remember
was walking, I felt
my calf muscles
just twitching like crazy
trying to keep me up.
And then my head it was
like-- it would just
flop over because you haven't
used your neck muscles.
As much working
out as we do, you
haven't used your neck
muscles in six months,
and so just getting my body
to remember that is actually
some mass at the
top of my shoulders
was the biggest thing.
And then, I can't leave you guys
without talking about the view
outside a little bit.
So this is the cupola
that I'm in right here,
and I had to give some
RPI love, but that's
a great-- I mean, that's
really what it looks like when
your floating in the cupola.
It's a great place to hang out.
It's even a better place
to hang out at night.
And I hijacked one little video
off the internet from YouTube.
It was some of Don Pettit's
imagery, but it's great.
This is coming down
over California
looking to the south, and
that little white dot there
is Las Vegas.
Now you can see Baja on
the right side coming down
over some thunderstorms
there, in the Pacific,
over Central America,
and then there's
where Central America
kind of necks down,
and then we'll work our way
down towards the South America
and Chile here in a minute.
And don't feel bad
about the fog here
because Chile is always living
it just like you guys are.
That's the line right
there of the fog
kind of pushing up
from the Pacific
onto Chile as we look south.
Chile is gorgeous.
Gorgeous, gorgeous place.
Coming down over Florida.
Florida and the
keys, and then Cuba.
Bunch of lightning storms
out over the Bahamas
and the Caribbean.
There's Orion rising
in the background.
This is over Asia.
The green lights
are fishing boats.
Coming down over all
of Europe, and then
Italy on the right side
with Sicily is very visible.
And then the
Mediterranean coming up
over Greece your hometown,
and then over Cyprus,
and there's Israel, Lebanon.
Off to the right is
Egypt, Cairo, the Red Sea.
Coming down over Saudi Arabia.
And then we were super lucky.
We had an amazing
aurora up there.
And if you want
to talk radiation,
we would fly through an
aurora about like this,
and then-- I was the IT
guy on the space station--
I would be changing out hard
drives on almost every laptop,
so that was the end of them.
HDD zero one error.
And the aurora were
just incredible.
I didn't really realize
that these are just
charged particles kind of
bouncing from poll to poll,
and you would just watch
then flicker at insane rates,
and snake their
way across the sky,
and you're just
floating through them.
You can never get
enough of the aurora.
And they go from green to red.
I've still never seen them from
Earth, which is unfortunate.
I got to fix that soon.
There's a lot-- I already
went to the Bahamas
because the view of the
Bahamas was so good.
When I came back I
grabbed my wife and kids
and we went to the Bahamas.
I just had to see what
those waters looked
like in real life, and
they were every bit as good
as I thought they would be.
And then, just to end, everybody
likes pictures of themselves?
Well, I guess this
is a picture of LA
mainly, so this isn't
a good one to show,
but you can see Baja California
is running off to the left,
and we're looking to the
west out to the Pacific.
There's a little, tiny Naval air
station somewhere around here
of El Centro, and
then LA is that kind
of gray smudge on the lower
right side of the screen there.
And it sounds funny,
but that's really--
Manhattan is the
biggest gray smudge
on the face of the planet.
I mean, it's just
amazing, and that's
all the cities look like
until you look at them
through a really long lens.
This is looking up now
into the Central Valley,
and a little bit of fog
in the Bay Area there.
And then, what turned out to
be one of my favorite views--
this is just to the east
of the Central Valley
looking back to the west,
and just look at our country.
I mean, I love it.
All the valleys, all
the mountains, and then
looking back into
the Central Valley.
And maybe it's fog or smog.
I'm not sure.
I think it's a little
bit of farming,
and then off to the coast.
But the West half of
the US was amazing.
Once you cross the east
half where I grew up
in Maryland and all that.
Once you cross the Mississippi
it just turns into green forest
and it's absolutely boring.
There's just nothing to
see unless it's nighttime,
and at nighttime
you can see it all.
I love this photo.
This is you guys at
night, so Bay Area's here.
You got LA off to the right.
Vegas is this white square of
lights that's very obvious.
But even this far south, just
avert your eyes a little bit
to the left and there's
the aurora up over Canada,
and really amazing.
And this is a good
representation
here about the
amount of stars you
would see with your human
eye at night and the aurora.
That's about a
human perspective.
Then I had really
nice, long lens.
An 800 millimeter, and some
new cameras came about halfway
through, and then I could start
to get some really cool city
imagery.
So there's a better view
of the Bay Area, San Jose,
and was able to snake
one at night too.
So San Jose is on
the right there.
Obviously you guys know
this area better than I do,
but the night stuff was
so cool because it's just
such a vivid thing.
And then I threw this one
in because it's Google.
A kid asked me to go down and
take a longer exposure just
so he could see a
lot of stars, and I
don't know why I hadn't thought
of doing that but I did it.
And when I saw this pop up
on the display of the camera
I was just completely
beside myself,
and it really changed the
way I think about everything.
And I think that's what you guys
do so well here Google is just
changing, looking around
the data at different angles
and seeing something
you didn't expect.
I expected the Milky
Way there in the center.
We've all seen that,
but what I didn't expect
was this awesome red
hue here, and then
this little green band that goes
across the atmosphere, and then
the whole Earth is kind
of lit up in this yellow.
And Alex and I were talking for
a long time about what it is,
and he was thinking, and
I agree with him, is we're
over the Saharan
Desert right here
and it's probably dust
and sand particulates
that's just floating
around in the atmosphere.
So with that, I think
I'll stop talking,
and I'll let you guys
ask some questions.
If I get this video to play--
I'll just move forward here
for a second and
just let some-- it's
just some funny, goofy video
but it'll make a good backdrop
while we're asking questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Can
use the microphone.
REID WISEMAN: This
is one of our best--
MALE SPEAKER: We're live here?
REID WISEMAN: Yeah.
Human perspective.
This is Alex giving me a
cappuccino after lunch,
so he would do one and then I
would be one, and it was good.
AUDIENCE: So I'm Kevin.
You talked about how
you were in the Navy.
I was too actually.
I was part of the Nimitz
Striker on the USS Chosen.
What did you fly
on, or what carrier?
REID WISEMAN: I started
on the-- yeah, carriers.
I start on Abraham Lincoln.
I did two deployments on the
Lincoln, and then I went over.
I did-- yeah, just
managing food.
And then I did a couple
deployments on the--
[LAUGHTER]
Did a couple of deployments
on the Eisenhower,
so they were my main boats.
I did a little stint on
the George Washington
as we took it around
South America, which
was also a really neat cruise.
Got to go through the
Straits of Magellan,
and that was when I bought my
first digital SLR was because I
was going to take a
carrier through the Straits
of Magellan, and I didn't want
to do that without photos.
And everybody made
fun of me because I'd
be up at 5:00 in the
morning in Tierra Del Fuego
taking pictures of sunrises, and
all my friends were like, ah,
you're a pilot.
You shouldn't be doing that.
But some of the most
beautiful things
I've ever seen in my life
was going through the Straits
of Magellan.
It's a great place.
AUDIENCE: We were west coast.
We didn't do that.
REID WISEMAN: Take a
sailboat through there.
AUDIENCE: So I've heard
through various stories
that the Russian space toilet
is the preferred space toilet.
Is that true, and if so, why?
REID WISEMAN: So the
Russian space toilet
is so much the
preferred space that we
have two of them up there,
and the Americans basically
just bought the
Russian space toilet
and we put it on our segment.
We used to have--
when the shuttle flew,
the shuttle had its own toilet.
It was a very good system.
I never got to use it in space.
I've seen it on the ground.
I haven't used it on
the ground, but it
was a very, very good system.
But it was also
extremely complicated.
And the Russian system is
really just a small separator,
which is like the pump
in a vacuum cleaner,
and it just draws a
little suction regardless
of which way you're going.
And it's not extremely
simple, but it's
very simple in comparison
to the shuttle system.
And so everything
inside the guts
of that we can
just jump in there
and fix, repair, swap
parts out, no problem.
I mean, we did three or four
repairs on the space toilet
while we were up there, and so
the Russian one is definitely
the preferred toilet.
AUDIENCE: Now I know.
REID WISEMAN: Now you know.
AUDIENCE: I've
wondered for years.
AUDIENCE: How long did
it take you to get back
to normal health once you
got back, and are there
any long term or permanent
effects, especially
from radiation and the auroras?
REID WISEMAN: Great question.
So I'll start from today
and I'll work backwards.
So even just
standing here today I
have a little bit of
discomfort in my spine
as my back muscles
continue to work,
and our spine kind of softens.
They're doing some
research on it right now.
I wasn't a part of this study.
It's really just starting,
but our spine actually
softens quite a bit
in space, and so
I think it's going pretty
interesting research when
they look at what's going on.
But that's been the
big, long term thing,
is just getting my
back back in shape.
And then my stamina.
I will leave here, and if
I sit down on the couch
I will take a nap
instantaneously.
And I didn't used to do that,
but ever since I came back
from space I think
my body's gotten
used to being a little
bit lazy in zero G. Yeah,
dancing is never good
in a public forum,
and this is going on YouTube.
And so right after
landing, the biggest thing
was leg muscles, and my feet.
I would stand-- I have
a tile kitchen floor,
and I do like to cook,
so I'd be cooking dinner
the second or third
day I was back,
and after about 20 minutes
I just had to sit down.
My feet could not take
that pressure anymore
on the bottoms of them.
And just kind of getting you're
nervous system back running.
I was a little bit sloppy.
I'd been back home week and
I was feel really good--
pretty arrogant
really-- and I just
went to flip a screwdriver
over and catch it,
and it whiffed completely.
I mean, I didn't have any
altitude on it at all.
It started to flip and went
right to the garage floor,
and so I realized I was way
off where I should have been.
But it all came
back really quick.
So you think about
landing on Mars,
and you could get right
out of the vehicle
and just start working
if you really needed to.
The human body is a
pretty impressive machine.
AUDIENCE: You were
pointing out when
we were looking at
the space station
from the outside at
the green solar panels,
and I heard you
say thermal panels?
REID WISEMAN: Yeah, we--
AUDIENCE: that
something different?
REID WISEMAN: --have a couple
extremely over engineered
radiators that are supposed
to exhaust our heat out
into space, and they are used.
We run ammonia through
them as the coolant lines
on the external side, and then
water on the internal side.
And we do use them,
but their capability
is way beyond the
heat rejection,
in the end, that we really need.
The technology behind
them is pretty fantastic.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe
should explain
why the heat exchangers?
Because it's getting
hot on sun side, right?
REID WISEMAN: Well, yeah.
This is really what's going
through our internals,
like all of our
internal operations.
And so outside the
space station we're
running around plus
or minus 300 degrees
as we go around the earth into
the daylight and into shade.
And so we have shell heaters
to keep it warm at night,
and then we need some way
to radiate this heat away
in the day.
So we use that, we
use coatings, we
use a thermal blankets,
stuff like that,
but then those big
radiators are mainly
just taking the heat from
inside and rejecting them out
into space.
If any of you guys
follow the World Cup,
this is Alex getting
ready to tell me
if Germany beats America then
we have to shave our heads.
And so this was the
last day I had there
hair quite awhile in space.
And then, if we had beaten
Germany we were going to paint
and American flag on
his head with some--
we had found some
paint up there.
And sure enough, we lost.
And I did not want to
shave my head at all.
Not at all.
It took some good convincing
from our commander
to get me to go.
And so we shaved our heads,
and we had to stop for a while
to Mohawk stage.
And took about a half a
day in space with Mohawks
and then we went
the rest of the way.
Cutting your hair in space
is-- it's actually great.
You just hook a vacuum cleaner
up to the back of the clippers
and go to town.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
MALE SPEAKER: Hold on.
AUDIENCE: That guy's trying
to spin around there.
I saw a video from [INAUDIBLE]
and they were doing cat videos,
and dropping them, and seeing
if he could flip over it.
Were you guys part of that?
REID WISEMAN: We were not
part of that, but I tell you,
if have I had a cat up there I
would have definitely dropped
it.
I don't think much
would have happened.
It would have just
floated there,
but no, we weren't
a part of that.
AUDIENCE: Because I remember
them talking about that
and I was like, wait a minute.
I don't know if
that's him or not.
REID WISEMAN: [LAUGHS] Nope.
Wasn't us.
One thing that it kind of
brings to my mind though is I
thought often about I wish I had
a 10-year-old up there with me
because their brains
are so adaptive,
and their bodies
are so adaptive.
And the things that
they would think
of-- like, my kids
right now will just
pull out their iPad Minis and
just go to town, and doing
stuff that I don't
even know to do,
but they just know how to do it
because they're just sponges.
And so, I hope someday
in our lifetime
we'll get where we have
commercial space station up
there, and we can send
some kids up, and just
watch them go nuts.
I think it'd be really fun.
They'd be more nuts.
This is us doing fake
morning calisthenics.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER:
Reid, why don't you
say something about your social
networking stuff from space?
You're known for that, right?
REID WISEMAN: Yeah,
but it's a competitor,
so I can't talk about that.
MALE SPEAKER: That's fine.
Come on.
REID WISEMAN: So
I didn't intend--
I was a rookie going on
a long duration mission,
and we haven't had a whole
lot of rookies at NASA
that have launched straight
into long duration space flight.
Most times, most of
these older folks
have gone up on the shuttle,
spent two weeks in space,
and come back and kind of
ease their way into it.
So I didn't really want to do
a whole lot on social media.
Swanee he's our athletics
trainer pretty much.
I mean, the guy's amazing.
So I didn't want to do a
whole lot on social media,
but I did want to
share what it is like
because most people have
the dream of weightlessness
and going into space.
I just wanted to
share that little bit,
so when I got up there I wanted
to put some of my emotions.
What are my feelings?
So I talked about how my body
felt, how I didn't feel great,
what was going on
in the treadmill,
and then I realized
the view outside
is also extremely captivating.
And so I just started taking
pictures and throwing them
online.
And with the help of
some folks at NASA,
that Twitter account exploded.
And I also really wanted
to take this world
and put it in motion.
Just watching Alex
here fake swimming
through the Japanese
segment of the space station
is hysterical, and so I wanted
to kind of put motion into it.
And so Vine had just started a
little bit before we launched,
and when I first got to
space we were in an area
around the sun called high
beta where the sun never
set for us in our orbital track,
and so we would go all day long
with no sunsets.
But when I would
look out the cupola,
the sun just did a slow loop
over the course of the day.
And I thought that
was hysterical,
so I took a Vine
of that, and that
was the first Vine from
space where the sun's just
always doing this
circle around the sky.
Vine's a really neat way to
just share-- the human attention
span is shrinking.
We can blame Twitter
for that, I don't know,
but Vine's six and a half
seconds of low grade video
seemed to be a great
recipe for space.
[LAUGHTER]
I got to share lightning
storms, and the lightning
from space when you're looking
down on that from above
was probably the most
fascinating thing.
Just watching all the
different kinds of lightning,
and how it would creep
across the clouds,
and just getting to
throw that online
and share it was magnificent.
And now I have a whole
journal of my time
up there, which is really neat.
And I've used it a
lot since I came back.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully this
isn't too space political,
but tagging onto your point
about the commercial space
station, what are
your thoughts on SLS
and the Orion capsule versus
SpaceX and commercial space
flight?
REID WISEMAN: You
know, it's kind
of the difference between
a Ferrari and a Ford F-150
pickup.
Each one is great
in their own respect
is the easiest way to put it.
So Orion and SLS, if we
just launched that thing
to the space station it would
be a colossal waste of money.
So we're talking about heavy
lift, long duration getting
stuff, really far away
from the Earth, and to do
that we need to put a
lot of mass into orbit.
So that's what SLS is
going to do with Orion.
And we just launched Orion in
November on a first flight test
and it when exceedingly well.
And so that program is
actually looking pretty good.
And the SLS is a really
reconfigurable capable rocket
so you can strap
on extra boosters
and put more mass in, or
take some boosters off
if you don't need it.
So I really like where
that's going because I
want to go as far as we can.
As a human being,
exploration is awesome,
and I want to do
as much as we can.
But then when you look
at a SpaceX model,
they're really just trying
to get a little bit of mass
to the space station.
And what's great
about them is they're
doing it super
efficient, super cheap,
and when you take away
all the layers of,
I guess I could say
bureaucracy, they
can strip it right
down to the bare bones
like you guys do here every day.
And you can innovate,
configure, test.
Didn't work-- change.
Fly another one, test,
change, and the way
that they've eased
into this is launching
cargo for a few years.
They've learned a ton,
and now their design
for launching humans has
evolved a lot from all of that.
And so hopefully
2017, 2018-- I think
it'll be more like 2018-- we'll
be putting humans on that.
And then we also have Boeing.
Boeing is building a
capsule, so we have
a parallel path which I love.
So if somebody
encounters a problem,
we can always work around.
Having a couple options, I
mean, that's the American way
and that's great.
And then, we're waiting
for the Google design,
but I don't know if it's coming.
MALE SPEAKER: (Jokingly)
That's obviously classified.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not going to
talk about that today.
AUDIENCE: So are we
ready to send people
to Mars, and if not,
what's standing in our way?
REID WISEMAN: It's
a great question,
and it's one that I can only
talk very high level too.
I'd say radiation is
standing in our way.
I'd say supplies is
When I looked at my food
and the amount of waste--
not food waste but packaging
waste because everything
has to be in a plastic
bag for rehydratables,
and then there's gotta be a
little radiation shielding
around that.
And if I just thought of
all the food-- I mean,
I would look at all this
mass and packaging of food.
So just the sustainability of us
has to get a little bit better.
From the oxygen, water,
CO2, scrubbing bathroom side
I think we've got
a great system,
and if you have
enough spare parts
you're going to
be in good shape.
3D printing is going to
really be a fantastic thing
for us to be able to just print
spare parts, spare tools-- that
really will be a game changer.
And we had a 3D printer up
there right when I left.
Unfortunately, I didn't get
it hooked up in time to print,
but they've been printing up
there on a first generation,
and then they're going to
have second generation soon.
So that one's going to be great.
And then the other one
that's the unknown factor
is radiation.
And when you get outside of the
protective layers of the Earth,
and you spend 500
days outside of that,
radiation is going to
be kind of a big deal.
But MSL just went out, it
had radiation detectors
all over it, and
actually, the picture
looks a little better
than we thought.
And so, I think it seems
like it's a pipe dream,
but if somebody just
says, we're going to do it
and we're going to do it by
now, I think we could do it.
I was just reading about
Mars One this morning,
and they only need
a couple billion,
and they're going to try it.
The technology is-- it's
not there yet right now,
but all the underlying
levels are there,
and all we need is that driving
force to just say, all right,
we're going to go do it.
Let's just stop messing around.
Let's just go do it.
So I think it's
definitely possible.
I think we should see it
in our lifetimes hopefully.
It'd be great.
MALE SPEAKER: How does 3D
printing differ in Zero-G?
REID WISEMAN: I talked
to the guys a little bit
and they said it really
doesn't differ a whole lot.
The machine is pretty much
just like printing at home.
I don't know the
technicals of it.
It was made in space.
It made the 3D printer, so
look them up and buy them.
AUDIENCE: We saw
the fluid dynamics,
and you mentioned how you had
a lot of blood drawn from you.
How does the body
react to trauma?
And say there is
arterial bleeding,
or do the platelets reactant
and clot at the same rate?
How, like a physical trauma, a
bruise, does it heal quickly?
REID WISEMAN: The
only side that I
could talk to that from
because I'm not a doctor
and I just don't know enough of
the details of what's going on
inside me, but I can talk from
what happened to me while I
was up there and what I saw.
And so we'd get nicks
and cuts all the time,
and it seemed like the healing
rate was just like on earth.
It seem like your bleed
rate was just like on earth,
so your clotting functions
appear to be totally normal.
Your blood volume does change
because your body recognizes
that your blood is not
pooling in your legs,
so it just starts to shut off
a little bit of your blood
volume.
So when we come back to
Earth, just standing up
at the end of the
mission can lead
to passing out until you get
your blood volume back up.
But aside from
that, it appeared as
though our body, which
shouldn't operate in Zero G,
works really well
from that perspective.
And so we had one guy
get a small water burn,
and that healed up,
actually, pretty quick.
I was surprised.
So if you think in space,
like if you grab a hot pan
or you put your hand under hot
water, the first thing you do
is back away.
Well, I'd never thought
about this before,
but he got hit in
the back of his head
with a little bit of hot
liquid that had come out
of the water dispenser,
and the first thing he did
was smack it.
And now he's got
two places of burns,
and there's no way to
get it off until he
got clothing, and
towels, and stuff
like that to get this off.
And so he had some
blistering, and it scared me.
It was a moment where I had
never thought of hot water
as such a dangerous
thing, and then
in space, yeah, you could
really hurt yourself on that.
But we appeared
to heal just fine.
Good question.
MALE SPEAKER: Could you
hurt yourself with hot air?
I mean, you could make
a bubble of water,
you could make a bubble
of really hot air.
REID WISEMAN: You could.
Yeah, you definitely good.
Overall our ventilation
system thought
was kind of shedding that stuff,
but there's a lot of great ways
to hurt yourself.
I mean, I came very close
to breaking a finger.
You get stuff in your eyes, like
floating particulate every once
in a while, and so NASA's
really, really careful
about just any shard of metal.
I mean, now that's a very
scary thing when you're
out there floating around.
MALE SPEAKER: I remember
somebody was telling me
when he was on a
space walk, they
had a problem in their eyes
when the eyes started tearing,
and that those tears
became a blob over his eye
and he could barely see stuff.
REID WISEMAN: One of the
first things I noticed
was just when you
laugh so hard you cry,
then that's just
stuck in your eye,
and it just forms this
bubble in your eyes.
It's a very weird
feeling at first,
and so you're dabbing your
tears out of your eyes,
and I experienced that
quite a bit up there.
So yeah, for sure.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned some experiments
from Procter & Gamble.
Are they paying you guys
to do that, and if so,
how do you feel about that?
REID WISEMAN: I can probably
defer to some of our NASA folks
here, but we have
this organization now
called CASIS, which
is really trying
to bring in outside research.
And the space station, now that
we're extending out to 2024,
that's the pride and
joy of our operation,
is just getting these outside
people to fly their research.
And so almost all of it is going
to be some sort of joint work,
like working with NASA
to fly their research up
onto the space station.
But CASIS is really working on
turning around stuff extremely,
extremely quickly, which
NASA is not good at,
and getting this outside
thinking up there.
And the rodent
research that we're
doing right now with the mice
is one of the prime examples.
That has just
exploded, and they're
talking about our
utilization, at least
for the next five years,
of just being hardcore
looking at these things.
From a CASIS perspective,
looking at immune function,
looking at brain wasting--
all kinds of just crazy things
with the mice.
And so they may even
fly them for 180 days
and go through a whole life
cycle of them in orbit.
Really amazing to see.
And so I really
applaud the efforts
of trying to bring in
these outside people
to make it-- I don't think you
could ever make it necessarily
profitable, but just to open
it up and get things in space
quickly with some
great imagination
and see what happens.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
one more question.
So the space station
has been, what?
15 years now in orbit?
So that's a lot of
miles flown in orbit.
Was there ever an event
of micrometeorites,
micrometeorites-- what
am I talking about?
Micrometeors.
REID WISEMAN: We call it MMOD.
Damage from mircometeorites.
MALE SPEAKER: Hitting
and puncturing anything,
or like leaving a trace of
some sort on the space station.
REID WISEMAN: Absolutely.
We have holes all over it.
Little ones.
And the whole thing is
shielded in an MMOD shielding,
but the one example from my
flight are cupola windows.
We were looking out the
front window, go to bed,
get up the next
morning, and there's
almost a dime sized chip in the
outer surface of the window.
It's almost like you're
driving on the highway
and a rock hit you,
and you're like, hmm.
I mean, that was going 17,000
miles an hour plus, probably,
when it whacked us,
but those windows
are designed to take
it, and you just
hope you don't get another
hit in that exact same spot.
But the space station is very
well designed for all that.
It's holding up well.
When we were out
on a space walk,
I mean, you could look all
over little dings, and chips,
and nicks, and things like
that, but nothing like a hole.
Nothing like a giant
hole in the side of it,
so far we've been good on that.
AUDIENCE: All right, so you
mentioned that now you're
feeling discomfort standing
up for a while even now.
That's just after six
months of being up there.
Are you going to get the
chance to go up again,
or is that a one done thing?
REID WISEMAN: No,
I should definitely
get the chance to go
up again, hopefully
within about five years.
We'll see.
AUDIENCE: So is it just kind
of a wait until everyone
everything grows back, and you
can stand and do everything
regularly?
And then, or--
REID WISEMAN: No, I mean,
right now I could fly again.
I mean, when I talk about
discomfort it's extremely mild,
but I can still feel
it a little bit,
so it just lets me
know that I'm not
fully there all the way around.
I mean, the best
therapy for that right
now would be going back up and
getting back in weightlessness,
and stretching back out.
I grow a little over
an inch and a half
while I was up there, just
as my spine elongated.
And I made it to about six
feet tall, which was good.
And we have a growth
chart in node one
with people that have put their
names on the wall as they grow,
so it's a lot like your
parent's old house up there.
It's pretty cute.
AUDIENCE: So what
you're saying is,
if I want to grow I
should go up into space.
REID WISEMAN: Yeah,
will definitely
get about an inch and a half
of vertical out of that.
AUDIENCE:Yeah, so the
space station has been up
for a while-- 15 years.
Is living inside
the space station
still-- does it feel
like being inside
of a developmental aircraft
where you're still attaching
new things, and new
pumps are coming in,
and new procedures
to operate it?
Or is it pretty well
established on how
to use the space station?
REID WISEMAN: You would think
it's completely established,
and in the end it's
not at all established.
Everything is changing.
You guys would go up there
and laugh at the technology
because in order to get
stuff flown into space
the turnaround time
is pretty long,
and that's where CASIS
is trying to change that.
I mean, our computers
were these extremely old--
I think they're like
T520s or something.
You just look at these
computers like, wow.
But we just upgrade
to Windows 7,
which was pretty nice for us.
That was a big upgrade
they did there.
But no, everything is
changing, and we're learning.
We used to just do these
hardcore procedures that
were written out, and
now we're realizing
that instead of
the written word,
maybe we could just
put a five second video
clip in that just shows
you zooming into this panel
and turning on the switch
that you need to find
in a really hard location.
Instead of putting that
in 15 lines of procedures,
you just put it in
one little video,
and then that's embedded
in what they send up to us.
And I know some guys were just
under the water at this thing
called Nemo, and they were
all wearing Google Glass,
and running their
procedures right on that.
And so I see the functionality
for all that would fantastic.
And then the hardware
is all changing.
We're swapping out
our CO2 scrubbers.
They were not
on-orbit cleanable,
and so now we're changing
out all the filters
there to make them
on-orbit cleanable,
and that changes the whole game.
The CO2 we run a
bit higher up there
gives you a really bad
headache from time to time,
and that was one
thing that we learned.
Hey, the current design
just is not sufficient,
so now we're working
on this new design.
They're gonna fly it next year,
and they'll be vacuumable,
and it'll be much better.
We can run the CO2
down to a lower level.
So there is no way we
are like one and done.
It's innovate,
innovate, innovate.
Design changes, and try to
make it better, and keep going.
And so we are
using it absolutely
as a test bed for deep
space exploration.
AUDIENCE: So ISS has
a limited lifetime.
I understand 2024 at this point.
What happens if they
don't extend it?
Are they designing
the new iteration
to fly it out and depress it.
REID WISEMAN: The hope would be
that we can kind of turn over
to commercial entities and
let them run up in space.
I know Bigelow out in Las Vegas,
they have inflatable hab units,
kind of, and they're
going to actually attach
one of those to the outside of
the space station next year.
And so if that works
out really well-- it's
a great design-- then who knows?
Maybe Bigelow could be
operating a space station
with SpaceX rockets going up and
servicing it, and running all
these experiments for people.
Not just in the US, but all
the way around the world.
And you could just buy a package
for like a one month research
package, and fly your
hardware up there.
And you as a scientist can
go up, and do your research,
and come back.
And so that's where, I think,
we would love to see it go.
If there's a market to
drive it we'll wait and see,
but I think that there
could be if it's done well,
and SpaceX has definitely
proven that you
can cut the cost considerably.
All right, it's been a pleasure.
Thanks everybody
for your attention,
and thanks for
having me out here.
[APPLAUSE]